well it's a short time ago we spoke with
the White House principal deputy press
secretary Raj Shah here's the
conversation Raj Shah joins us tonight
from the White House so Raj these
indictments say that Russian
interference began in 2014 do you see
these 13 indictments as vindication for
you we absolutely do really there's
three main points that we see from these
indictments one as you mentioned they
started this plot started in 2014 before
the president jumped in the race and you
know what we also saw is that they prove
that there's no collusion the biggest
point that the president's been making
since before this investigation even
began the last point that this
investigation or rather these
indictments made clear is that all these
efforts were about sowing confusion in
the electoral process and undermining
the next president not about supporting
one candidate over the other and so
really when you see these efforts by
Democrats they're pushing this collusion
conspiracy what they're really doing is
doing the dirty work for the Russians
for them the media and the Democrats
making false claims are really pushing
what the Russians want them to push I
think that's true also paradoxically it
looks like Robert Muller who has been
seen as an enemy of the White House is
helping the White House's case tonight I
think that's right
you know we've always been cooperative
with the special counsels investigation
while the president has said that it's a
hoax that you know the the charge of
collusion is false he would be the one
to know we've still been cooperative
we've still provided witnesses documents
etc and now it's helped uncover this
elaborate plot you know with in many
Russian individuals that had no
cooperation active cooperation with the
Trump campaign and it really shows that
what Democrats have alleged have charged
and frankly made really outlandish
claims about is totally baseless but it
also sets the kind of interesting
precedent because as you well know
living in Washington there's a lot of
foreign interference into our politics
the Mexican government for example has
run
registration drives at American
consulates that seems like an obvious
effort to influence elections outcomes
do you think they're going to be
indictments there well I'm not a lawyer
and I wouldn't pledge to know exactly
what statutes you know may or may not
have been violated by other efforts I
would say that the only plot of actual
active collusion between a 2016 campaign
and a foreign government was Hillary
Clinton's government when it was
operating out of the Ukrainian embassy
in collusion with the DNC and trying to
drop opposition research on Donald Trump
and on members of the president's
campaign so you know there are examples
of foreign influence in campaigns and
there is an example of collusion in the
last campaign it just has nothing to do
with this president and his campaign so
but would you concede that we're
spending a lot of time examining and I
don't think it's bad but Russian
influence on our country our society our
politics do you think this is going to
kick off a new era where we take a close
look at the influence of a lot of other
countries on our politics and if not why
not well I think you know the issue of
foreign influence in American elections
is a serious one it's a real one you
know you just mentioned one example I'm
sure there are many others you look I
think we want yeah of course we want to
ensure that there's integrity in our
election process that individuals who
are voting for example are all
registered citizens that's an issue that
president has raised you know and he and
he initiated a commission last year
through an executive order to look at
the integrity of our election process we
hope that this is just one step in that
in that overall effort to make sure that
our elections are clean and fair and
influenced by Americans first and
foremost right shot from the White House
thank you very much thank you